i'm sorry i can't be with you to honor
two true heroes of global health victor
zadonov and bill faye with
the future of life award they're
phenomenal examples of what it means to
harness science for public health
the eradication of smallpox not only
prevented
unnecessary suffering and death it
showed the world that
diseases can be defeated and it reminds
us of the need for global cooperation
in fighting other diseases such as covet
19 malaria
polio and diseases we have yet to
encounter
i've never had the pleasure of meeting
dr donov but the more i learn about his
accomplishments the more i respect his
work
he played a leading role in getting
rival superpowers
to team up against smallpox
i do have the pleasure of knowing bill
faye
it's fair to say he was my first teacher
in global
health bill was one of the first people
melinda and i turned to when we began
learning about the subject
and he's had a huge influence on us
we wanted to understand what it took to
eradicate diseases so he turned to one
of the people
who'd had actually done it he gave me a
list of about 80 books and journals to
read
and i looked at all of them one
important thing i learned from that
assignment
was how much more i needed to learn
luckily bill has been there as helping
us
every step of the way also sharing his
knowledge
wisdom and passion he also has more
memorable quotes from ancient writers
than any other person i know
bill has set a phenomenal example for
everyone who cares about global health
as a physician teacher leader and
advocate for acting on the idea
that all lives have equal value
congratulations again
to bill and to the family of dr sadanov
and thank you all for your continuing
efforts to save lives around the world